هل انت غاضب من سياسه بوتين هل هذه هي
الحياه التي حلمت بها اسئله طرحت ضمن
فيديو عاطفي اعدته الاستخبارات الامريكيه
لمحاوله تجنيد المزيد من الجواسيس الروس
وهذه خطوه قد تصب الزيت على النار في
العلاقه المتوتره اصلا مع موسكو لكن ما
الهدف الاساسي من هذا الاعلان الامريكي
وكيف سيتواصل الروس مع سي اي اي الوكاله
نشرت الفيديو على منصه تيليجرام كونها
الوسيله الرئيسيه التي يستخدمها الروس
للحصول على معلوماتهم وتقول ان هدفها هو
معرفه الحقيقه بشان روسيا وانها تبحث عن
اشخاص موثوق بهم يمكنهم اخبارها بهذه
الحقيقه لتحسين اوضاعهم في الوقت ذاته
تقول انها لا تسعى الى اثاره تمرد او
تغيير النظام في موسكو طلبت ممن يرغب في
التواصل معها استخدام متصفح تور للوصول
الى شبكه المظلمه او دارك ويب وادوات
لتشفير الاتصالات اما عن توقيت نشر
الفيديو فيقول مسؤولون في الوكاله لسي ان
ان الحرب في اوكرانيا تعد فرصه غير مسبوقه
ويريدون استغلالها في المقابل وفي اول
تعليق لموسكو على الاعلان الامريكي اكد
الكرملين ان الاجهزه الامنيه الروسيه
تراقب هذا الفضاء بالطريقه الضروريه
برايكم هل سيكتفي الكرملين بهذا الرد فقط
[موسيقى]